Welcome students to
the Pharmacology of
Antiretroviral Agents,
Dr. Goldstein speaking.
This is one lecture in two
parts. We'll begin with an
overview to look at the
various drug targets and how
they relate to the replication
process of HIV, and two
drug classes, the nucleoside
reverse transcriptase
inhibitors and the integrase
strand transfer inhibitors.
Please contact me if you'd like
to talk about pharmacology.
The learning objectives
are the same for
both parts because
it is one lecture.
The therapeutic use is
central to the pharmacology
of these drugs.
They are used in
combination. The combinations
are going to be related
to the mechanisms
of action and to the
adverse effects, the
pharmacokinetic properties,
etc.
Here are some links.
basic statistics show
us that HIV is still a
problem with new cases
diagnosed with treatment
experienced patients who
need changes in their
therapy and with people
who thankfully are
adhering to therapy and
living into older age.
Here are the key points.
I won't go over them with
you. They're here for you,
help prepare you for the
lecture or to use them or
not use them. It's up to you.
Here's an electron
micrograph of HIV virus. This
is the small ground, small
green spheres, small green
circles attaching to a
white blood cell which is
the large orange colored
structure in the middle.
This is an excellent
resource that I strongly
advise you to look
at later on in your
practice when you do
need to have information
about HIV guidelines,
about HIV in general,
about opportunistic infections,
everything related to HIV.
Because care of HIV AIDS
patients has shifted from
specialists, infectious
disease specialists, to the
primary care physicians. And
primary care physicians are
strongly encouraged to be
trained in treating HIV.
Picture of the virus here
on the upper right side.
This outer kind of
fluffy region, this is
made up of glycoproteins,
glycoprotein GP120.
And here, extending
down, GP141.
We see the capsid and
the two retro, sorry,
reverse transcriptases
in the middle.
The lower figure is
showing us the docking.
Here's our HIV with our
GP120, and that will
dock to the host cell
by grabbing on to CD4.
and this opens up GP41
which will then sort
of pull the virus to
the host cell cause
fusion and it will
enter the host cell.
This is a picture of HIV
budding from the infected cell.
There are so, so, so many,
many, many variants of HIV.
And these are the
antiretroviral drug classes.
In this lecture we'll be
talking about these two.
Many antiretroviral drugs
are formulated in two
drug combinations and three
drug combinations. These
are called fixed-dose
combinations, which makes it
so much easier for patients
to stick to therapy.
If they can be taking
one pill once a
day, it really
encourages adherence.
Here is our HIV replication
process with drugs indicated
on here. We have our
drugs that prevent fusion.
We have our recent drug that
will inhibit the capsid.
We have drugs that inhibit
retrovirus, I mean reverse
transcriptase, RT, reverse
transcriptase. Drugs
that inhibit the integrase
step, the integration
into the host chromosome.
Drugs that inhibit the
splitting up of the
polyprotein, and therefore the
various proteins are not
released to be functional.
And here we have
the assembly, the
capsid inhibitor will
inhibit that again,
and budding and
release and maturation.
VIRAL RESISTANCE IS
A TREMENDOUS PROBLEM.
HIV REVERSE TRANSCRIPTASE
IS ERROR PRONE, LAX
APPROPRIATING FUNCTION,
AND MUTATIONS ARE
FREQUENT. THAT'S JUST
THE NATURE OF THE HIV.
IT HAS A HIGH MUTATION RATE AND
TREMENDOUS NUMBER OF
INFECTIOUS VARIANTS.
VIRAL LOGIC FAILURE IS
DEFINED AS THE INABILITY TO
ACHIEVE OR MAINTAIN SUPRESSION
OF VIRAL REPLICATION to an
HIV-RNA level of less than
200 copies per milliliter.
Transmitted drug
resistance is acquired
through person
-to-person spread,
and there is a high
likelihood that all untreated
infected individuals harbor
viruses with single amino
acid mutations that confer
some degree of resistance.
These are in untreated people.
Goals of therapy, we
always want to know what it
is we want to achieve
with our drug therapy so
we can monitor for it.
So maximally and durably
suppressed plasma HIV RNA,
so that's a viral load,
suppressing the
viral load, restoring
and preserving
immunologic function, CD4,
reducing HIV-associated
morbidity, prolonging the
duration and quality of
survival so the patient can
live a normal life, and
preventing transmission.
Antiretroviral therapy,
ART, is recommended in all
HIV-infected individuals
to prevent transmission.
These are all patient
populations who are
infected with HIV. Consistent
and effective use of
antiretroviral therapy
resulting in sustained
reduction in viral load
in conjunction with
behaviors are essential
tools for preventing
****** and blood-borne
transmission of HIV. The
principles of antiretroviral
therapy, the current
standard of care is 3 to 4
antiretroviral agents for
the entire duration of
treatment, which is lifelong.
Two NRTIs,
key, and an INSTi are
the preferred initial
antiretroviral regimen.
Alternatives for the
base, it's always going to
have two NRTIs as long
as we can find effective
ones, which we will in
the therapy-naive patient.
So we have a non
-nucleoside reverse
transcriptase inhibitor
or a boosted protease
inhibitor. So those
are the options.
Recently, fairly recently,
relatively recently,
some two drug regimens
have been approved for
selected patients. I'll
point that out later on.
The outcome of therapy should
be an undetectable viral
load within 24 weeks of
starting treatment. and CD4
count increase of 50 to 150
cells per cubic millimeter,
which is the same as a
microliter, in the first year.
Treatment failure generally
requires implementation
of a completely new
combination of drugs. And
treatment failure is usually
a result of non-adherence.
Adhering to the
therapy continuously is
essential for achieving
these outcomes.
the adverse effects of
antiretroviral therapy and
this is class effect just
for all of them has something
called immune reconstitution
inflammatory syndrome
as a person who has aids
who has a low cd4 count
is being treated with
effective antiretroviral
therapy. That CD4 count
will increase as the
viral load decreases.
And as it does, the host
immune system becomes
reconstituted, becomes active
again. And it will then
recognize and attack
subclinical opportunistic
infections or malignancies.
So you get this inflammatory
syndrome occurring.
There are, of course,
class and drug-specific
toxicities. As a general
statement, the later
generation drugs, and
we'll talk about first
generation and second
generation, are generally more
tolerable than the first
generation versions.
So we'll see that the
second generation versions
tend to be the ones that
are in clinical use.
And And nearly all of
them are associated with
significant pharmacokinetic
drug interactions.
And we're talking about
they are substrates
of these various
metabolic enzymes and P
-glycoprotein and certain
other efflux transporters.
Some of them are
inhibitors. Some of
them are inducers.
Some of them do both
of metabolic enzymes
and transporters.
So we'll begin with
the nucleoside reverse
transcriptase inhibitors,
and there is one
nucleotide reverse
transcriptase inhibitors.
As I go through, I'm
including both of
them, but I'll just
say nucleoside because
I don't want to say
the whole thing.
The ones in clinical
use at the moment
are listed here
with stars on them.
These on the bottom
are actually no longer
marketed. These are
first generation.
Zydovudane is the
first generation too,
but it has an
important clinical use.
So these two NRTIs
are referred to as
the backbone of
antiretroviral therapy.
And wherever possible,
there will always be two
NRTIs put together. And
I say whenever possible,
thinking about people
who are heavily
treatment experienced, which
means they are harboring
quite a variety of
resistant HIV strains.
This is just a
little slide to show
your definition. A
nucleoside is the
nucleic acid base
with the ribose on it.
Now, a nucleotide has
a phosphate group on
it, or two or three. So
if there's a phosphate
group there, it
becomes a nucleotide.
This is how the NRTIs
are categorized.
They are nucleotide analogs,
thymidine, cytidine,
guanosine, and adenosine.
Zydovudine is the one in this
group, the thymidine group.
These two, lamivudine and m
-tricitabine, are in
the cytidine group.
Abacavir is the only
one in the guanosine
group, and tenofavir
is in the adenosine
group. So let's talk
about what happens here.
These are really basically
pro-drugs because
they need to be phosphorylated
intracellularly,
and they are phosphorylated
by host kinases.
So, we get the parent
compound becomes
monophosphate, diphosphate,
triphosphate, and that
is the active form.
That is true for the cytidine
group and the guanosine group.
Tenofovir, however,
has a phosphate on it.
It is a nucleotide.
It is already coming
in with a phosphate.
Therefore, it gets
phosphorylated twice, and
they're calling that
the monophosphate, even
though this has a
phosphate on it already.
And it gets a second phosphate,
so it's a diphosphate,
but it actually has
three phosphates on it.
So it ends up to
be a compound with
three phosphates
on it. and so it'll
act the same way
as the other ones.
As I said, they're
phosphorylated
intracellularly and they
act by terminating the
elongation of the
proviral DNA chain due
to the absence of the
3' hydroxyl group.
This is the natural process.
We have our ribose here
and our 3' prime and the
phosphate from the previous
see here's the phosphate
on the five prime phosphate
from the previous will
bind there the drug however
this is the drug and
this is kind of flipped so
imagine it flipped here's
the three prime here you
see there is no hydroxyl
group so this step can't
occur so as a result we
get termination of the
elongation of the proviral
DNA chain due to the absence
of that 3-hydroxyl group
and we it also blocks
competitively inhibits
incorporation of the native
nucleotide into it so it's
a it's blocking here, and
it's also blocking here.
Viral resistance,
high level resistance
requires three to four
codon substitutions.
If these drugs are
used alone, it might
take a little while,
but it always occurs.
A single amino acid
substitution confers
high level resistance
to lamivudine
and M-tricitabine.
These are, recall,
structurally related.
In fact, they're very closely
related. M-tricitabine
is actually lamivudine
with a fluorine atom on it.
So high resistance
to these two drugs,
a lower level resistance
to abacavir, and this
is a four in the second
generation, abacavir,
lamivudine, m-tricitabine,
and tenofavir. Interestingly,
that mutation, the
methionine to the valine
or isoleucine at amino
acid number 184 restores
susceptibility to
tenofovir and zidovidine.
And I put a couple of
other mutations here.
K65R is also quite common
and cross resistance
is reported following
prolonged therapy. So I do
want you to remember
this particular mutation.
Now toxicity.
Something called
mitochondrial toxicity,
a very important
concept to understand.
It's been well documented
with the first generation
NRTIs. There are other
drugs that also cause
mitochondrial toxicity
that are not part of this
lecture at all. It is a
concept you do need to
understand and recognize
in your clinical practice.
So, how does this happen?
Well, these NRTIs inhibit
reverse transcriptase,
which is polymerase,
and they do not inhibit
our own polymerase, except
for the DNA polymerase
gamma, which is in the
mitochondria. And as a
result of this inhibition,
inhibiting the DNA polymerase
gamma from doing its
job, then the mitochondria
function breaks down.
these older generation
drugs are the ones
that are highly associated
with the mitochondrial
toxicity especially
zelcytabine which
was the first one to
have been withdrawn
zidovudine is down
here towards the
bottom but it can
still cause it
And the rest of them,
the second generation,
are really
associated with a low
potential for this
mitochondrial toxicity.
So what are the manifestations?
I listed it down here.
Myopathy, peripheral
neuropathy, lipoatrophy,
lactic acidosis,
hepatic steatosis.
And this lipoatrophy, hepatic
steatosis, I put
especially right here.
because it's a very, very
serious adverse effect,
adverse drug event, and it
can be fatal. So people who
are presenting with signs
or symptoms of mitochondrial
toxicity, the drug must be
stopped, and the patient
must be evaluated. Now,
other toxicities that occur
with NRTIs may be related
to mitochondrial toxicity,
pancreatitis, bone marrow
suppression, and
cardiomyopathy.
These are important for
students to remember.
They are really relevant
on board exams, but more
importantly, they're really
relevant to patient care.
Some specific features
here now of these
different drugs. We'll
start with tenofovir.
Tenofovir comes
in two salt forms,
disoproxel fumarate
and alafenamide. So
that's what those letters
DF and AF stand for.
So you'll see tenofovir
written by its acronyms TDF
and TAF. much shorter than
writing out the whole word.
They are oral well
-absorbed P-glycoprotein
substrates. They are not
substrates of CYP3A4. In
fact, they have minimal
hepatic metabolism
and they go out through
the urine as tenofovir.
I put half-lives here in
terms of the intracellular
half-life because that's
what really counts.
The intracellular half-life
is from 10 hours to 50 hours.
Tenofovir disaproxyl
fumarate is rapidly converted
after absorption to tenofovir.
And then the tenofovir
circulates and is taken
up by the host cells.
This is an important
distinction with its daughter,
tenofovir alafenamide.
TAF is administered at
lower doses, so naturally
it achieves lower
plasma concentrations.
That's a typical
pharmacokinetic property.
However,
the intracellular
concentrations of
the active tenofovir
diphosphate,
that's three phosphates,
don't forget, are higher.
Now, why is this?
Because TAF
circulates as itself.
It circulates as
TAF, whereas TDF
is rapidly converted
to tenofavir.
Now, TAF is taken up into
cells, and it is inside
the cell that the TAF
is first metabolized to
tenofavir and then to
the diphosphate, which of
course has three phosphates
on it. So that's the
difference there, and
we're going to see that
that is an important
difference in a few moments.
The therapeutic
applications of both of them
are the same. They're
interchangeable, and you
can see here how very
important these drugs are.
First-line NRTIs for
the treatment of HIV-1,
pregnant patients
all trimesters,
children from 2 years old,
people from 2
years old. However,
the alafetamide
TAF is for older
pediatric patients
from 12 years old.
Pre-exposure prophylaxis,
post-exposure
prophylaxis, and now
hepatitis B virus.
That's going to become
relevant in a moment.
So tenofovir, TDF and TAF
are used as monotherapy for
the treatment of chronic
HPV, and they are effective.
And also for prophylaxis
in patients who are
immunocompromised and likely
to be introduced to HPV.
Both TDF and TAF suppress
HBV infection, obviously,
so if they are withdrawn,
severe acute exacerbation
of HBV infection
can occur as HBV replication
is increased, and
it can be increased to
a great rate, and that
can lead to hepatitis,
liver inflammation.
It is, after all,
a liver virus.
So in patients who
are co-infected with
HIV and HBV, treated
with tenofovir,
then they may, very
likely, will need
to have another anti
-HBV drug started.
Adverse effects.
generally well-tolerated,
which is great since
they're a component
of just about the vast
majority of antiretroviral
therapy regimens.
Main toxicities, kidney
and bone adverse effects,
renal impairment, which can
be seen with increases in
serum creatinine, protein
spilling into the urine,
glucose spilling
into the urine,
hypophosphatemia, and
acute tubular necrosis.
Kidney injury with proximal
tubular dysfunction.
This is a syndrome
called Fanconi syndrome.
Acute kidney injury,
chronic kidney disease,
nephrogenic diabetes,
insipidus. So what are we doing?
We have to, whenever a
person is on to nofavir,
the renal function
absolutely must be monitored.
And the drug also causes
a decrease in bone mineral
density. Now I mentioned
before, the TAF is
administered in lower doses
and it is also associated
with less long-term
kidney and bone toxicity.
Drug interactions.
Well, putting tenofovir
with abacavir together
is associated with
high rates of virologic
failure, so those two
NRIs aren't combined.
P-glycoprotein inhibitors.
Ritonavir, which is
frequently used in ART
and cabecostats, same deal,
may increase tenofovir
levels. What are we
thinking about here?
Toxicities.
TAF only. P-glycoprotein
inducers are contraindicated.
They will reduce
the efficacy of TAF.
because of decreased
TAF levels as the
drug gets pumped out
of the circulation
or is prevented
from getting into
the circulation in
the first place.
So TAF only, P-glycoprotein
inducer. So what are they?
Well, these are drugs
you've seen before.
Rifampin, carbamazepine,
oxcarbazepine,
phenytoin, phenobarbital.
We talked about
them as inducers of
CYP3A4. They also
induce P-glycoprotein.
Moving now to M-tricitabine
and lamivudine. These
are cytidine analogs. M
-tricitabine is fluorinated
lamivudine, and they
should not be used
together because they will
compete with each other
and therefore
reduce the efficacy.
Oral, well-absorbed,
good bioavailability,
excreted in urine on chains.
You see this pattern?
Half-life of lamivudine
intracellular is 10 to 15
hours and it is adequate
for one's daily dosing.
M-tricitabine is longer but
it's also dosed once a day.
Both of these drugs also
suppress HBV infection.
Lamivudine is
approved for HBV but
HBV is mostly resistant
to lamivudine.
M-trizytabine is not approved
for it, but it suppresses
HPV. So in individuals
who are co-infected with
HIV and HPV, withdrawal of
lamivudine or M-trizytabine
can lead to exacerbation
of HPV and hepatitis.
resistance we talked about
the m184 valine isoleucine
point mutations for high
level resistance these two
also cause reduced
susceptibility the drugs are well
tolerated this is a drug
specific effect this
hyperpigmentation caused by m
-tricitabine that usually only
occurs mostly on the hands
and the soles of the feet
abacavir and zidovidine
now these two are not
related to each other unlike
the other two slides i
showed you so abacavir is
a guanosine analog oral
well absorbed now this
one undergoes hepatic
metabolism by alcohol
dehydrogenase dehydrogenase
and glucuronal transferase.
It goes out through the
urine as metabolites. And
the half-life intracellular
is 12 to 26 hours. It
is given once a day.
It is converted
intracellularly to this
compound called carbovir
monophosphate, which will
then become the active
carbovir triphosphate.
So that's a special
feature of abacavir.
Here's another very
important special feature.
HLA-B5701 allele.
All patients must be
screened for this allele.
Okay, so what happens?
What is the potential
problem in patients
who have this allele?
Hypersensitivity
reactions with multi-organ
involvement that is
potentially fatal.
Therefore,
abacavir should never
be given to patients
who are positive for
HLA-B5701 genotype.
or restarted in
patients who have
had a hypersensitivity
reaction.
Resistance, here we have
our 184 again and K65.
Abacavir is frequently
paired with lamivudine
as a component of
the NRTI backbone.
I mentioned before, don't
pair it with tenofavir
because of the high
rate of virologic
failure. And in terms of
drug interactions, well,
alcohol can increase
abacavir levels because
of competition for
alcohol dehydrogenase.
Cidovudine, the
thymidine analog.
This is given twice a day
when it's given ******.
it's mostly used intravenously
and we'll see when we get as i
mentioned this is
a first generation
nrti and it does not have
much use anymore however
it does have very important
use when it comes to
pregnancy and we'll talk
about that when we get there
It does have hepatic
metabolism by glucuronal
transferase. A lot
of it is excreted
unchanged in the urine, and
it's got an intracellular
half-life of only
about seven hours.
The others clearly
have advantages
that zidovidine does not.
perinatal IV infusion
to prevent vertical
transmission, and it's
also for neonates. So
those are the two major
uses of zidovudine.
Some questions, review
questions, if you would like
to pause your video and see
if you can answer them on
your own. What are the
important clinically relevant
takeaways about the PK
properties of the NRTI's class?
How is viral resistance
related to the
NRTI's mechanism of
action and effects?
How is mitochondrial
toxicity related
to the NRTI's
mechanism of action?
And here are the answers.
Oral minimal systemic
metabolism, except for
abacavir. Active drug
excreted in the urine, once
daily dosing, that's the
second generation drugs.
Point mutations in reverse
transcriptase amino acids
at the drug's binding
sites. We talked about M184,
thionine to valine or
isoleucine. Confers high-level
resistance to lamivudine
and M-tricitabine, but
improves susceptibility of
tenofavir and cydovidine.
K65R confers reduced
susceptibility to all four
NRTIs. The NRTIs, the first
generation especially,
bind mitochondrial
DNA polymerase gamma,
resulting in myopathy,
peripheral neuropathy,
lipoatrophy,
lactic acidosis,
hepatic steatosis,
and possibly pancreatitis.
This is a low potential with
the second-generation NRTIs.
More questions.
What are the main toxicities
of tenofovir and abacavir?
Which of the second
-generation NRTIs should not
be combined, and why? What
screening tests must be
performed prior to
administering abacavir, and why?
What drugs can cause
reactivation of HPV
and hepatitis when
withdrawn in patients
with HIV? HIV, HBV co
-infection. And I'll
give you a moment to
pause your computer,
your video.
The tenofovir causes kidney and
bone toxicity,
particularly the TDF,
the disoproxyl fumarate salt,
impaired renal function,
proximal tubule dysfunction,
Fanconi syndrome, that
is, acute kidney injury,
chronic kidney injury,
nephrogenic diabetes insipidus.
And I also asked about
abacavir and forgot to put
it on here, which is the
hypersensitivity reaction.
Lamivudine and m-tricitabine
should not be put together
because they're really
the same drug and they
compete with each other for
intracellular phosphorylation
and that's going to decrease
their effectiveness.
Screening tests about
abacavir is the HLA-B57 star
5701 associated with severe
multi-organ hypersensitivity
reactions in patients
positive for this
allele and lamivudine
amtricitamine tenofavir. All
can cause reactivation
of HBV and hepatitis when
withdrawn in patients who
are co-infected with HPV.
And now the integrase
inhibitors or with their long
name is integrase strand
transfer inhibitors, the
INSTIs. These five are
important in therapy. In fact,
the INSTI is first line
base to go with the 2NRTI
backbone. They have activity
against HIV-1 and 2.
NSTs are well-tolerated,
highly effective,
and have a high
barrier to resistance.
I've put here really just
the clinically relevant
information of the
NSTs. I've divided it
into second generation,
which I have on the left
side, and first generation
on the right side.
The second generation
are the preferred NSTs.
They're all once daily
except for raltegravir.
Raltegravir is once
daily only at the
higher dose. Otherwise,
it's twice daily.
The first three are
available in combinations.
That's what this is.
Raltegravir is not.
especially because of
originally it was always
only twice a day and the
others are once a day
so
we have our three here
and this little c on here
stands for kubicastat
because it is boosted it has
to be have a pharmacokinetic
enhancer on it with
kubicastat that's how it's
formulated it's formulated
in these four drugs
elvitegravir kubicastat
tenofavir and m-tricitamine
virologic efficacy so
what does this mean is
the drug effective in
individuals harboring
elvitegravir or reltegravir
resistant hiv well it
is known that dolutegravir
does need a higher
dose but it does in
vitro with bictegravir
yes but the clinical data
are not available yet
adverse effects these
are class adverse effects
here weight gain nausea
diarrhea headache insomnia
these are quite common
depression and suicidality
are rare generally
occurring in patients
who already have psychiatric
conditions and here
are drug specific adverse
effects I leave it to
you to work through those.
You should know them.
CYP3A4 drug-drug
interactions that I've
been going on about
all of these months
because they matter
to patient care.
Bictegravir is a
CYP3A4 substrate.
Dolutegravir, to some
extent, but its drug levels
can still be affected by
inducers or inhibitors.
Elvitegravir is a
CYP3A4 substrate and it
needs boosting so a
CYP3A4 inhibitor with it.
Raltegravir no it is a
no CYP3A4 or CYP at all.
I'm going to jump down
here to other significant
DDIs. Here's our p
-glycoprotein again.
So bictegravir,
anything that affects p
-glycoprotein or UGT1A1.
P-glycoprotein UGT1A1.
UGT1A1.
UGT1A1. That's
easy to remember.
And acids.
Oral absorption
of instes may be
reduced by polyvalent cations.
So, antacids should not
be taken at the same time.
Separate by at least two hours.
Mechanism of action
is illustrated here.
The instes block the catalytic
activity of HIV-encoded
integrase to prevent the
integration of the virus
DNA into the host chromosome.
So here's a picture of
virus DNA inserting itself
into the host chromosome.
And here's a picture of,
in this case, raltegravir,
the first one to be developed,
blocking that effect.
Human beings do not
have integrase, so these
drugs are completely
selective for HIV. activity
is HIV one and two potent
used for treatment naive
and treatment experienced
patients of all ages resistance
you don't have to remember
these but the concept
is the same point mutations
at the site of action and
as these point mutations
occur additional mutations
can accumulate and that
can lead to high level
resistance and cross resistance
these drugs must be used
together in a potent
antiretroviral therapy regimen.
Drugs are well-tolerated. Some
had egg GI effects,
which we saw.
Now, cabotegravir
is not on that list
because it has, actually,
everything about it is
different, and I'll talk
about that on the next slide.
Dolotegravir and
Bictegravir have
a high barrier to resistance.
Reltegravir and
Elvitegravir, a lower barrier
to resistance. And these
are first generation.
These are second generation.
Now, Cabotegravir is a long
-acting intramuscular
suspension.
It was developed for two
-drug therapy in selected
patients. So not three
drugs anymore. You
see there's no NRTI on
this treatment regimen.
It can only be administered
into the gluteal muscles.
and therefore this is an
interesting side note that
we haven't seen before
in our pharmacology that
we've talked about it
may not be an option for
people who have buttocks
implants or fillers because
that's the only place
that it is to be injected
cabotagravir is paired
with rilpivirine so it
also comes in an oral form
and this is specifically
for an oral lead-in
so the pill is taken
once a month once a day
for a month the whole
idea is to make sure the
patient tolerates it,
along with rapivirine
oral for a month, and then
the switch over, that's
the wrong circle, the
switch over to the IM
form, which can be given
every four weeks or every
eight weeks, or it can
be said as every once a
month or twice a month,
and that's going to
be a patient-specific
decision between the
prescriber and the patient.
Now, the oral is also
useful for bridging
therapy in case the
patient knows they're
going to miss the
scheduled IM dose, and
so they can bridge it
over with the oral.
But this is selected
patients. This is only two
drugs. So the patient
will need to have been on
the typical three-drug
antiretroviral therapy.
The patient must
have no baseline
resistance to either
medication, naturally,
because if the patient
is resistant to one,
then it's the same
as having only one
drug on board. No prior
virologic failures.
No HBV, unless they're
also on a drug for HBV.
They're not pregnant. They're
not planning on becoming
pregnant. And they are
not receiving medications
with significant drug
interactions with
cabotegravir or repilverine.
So these are basically
stable patients, and they've
been stable over time.
No virologic failures.
Cabotegravir, or just
cabotegravir, is also used for
pre-exposure prophylaxis in
HIV negative individuals.
Some
questions. What properties
make insties the
preferred first-line
choice for ART backbone?
Which two are the first
-line insties? What
is the role of cabotegravir
-repivirin-2 drug
art in the treatment
of HIV-1? What is
another therapeutic use
of cabotegravir? I am.
I'll give you a moment to
pause your video, if you wish.
Insties are well-tolerated,
highly effective,
and have a high
barrier to resistance.
Dolotegravir and Bictegravir
are second-generation
insties with a higher,
it's actually a high
barrier to resistance,
higher than the first
-generation insties, and
they are available in
fixed-dose combinations,
allowing one pill once
daily dosing for improved
patient adherence.
Cabotegravir, Rilpivirin is
indicated for patients who
have no baseline resistance
to either medication, No
prior virologic failures,
do not have active HPV
unless they're taking a drug
for it, are not pregnant and
are not planning on becoming
pregnant, and are not
receiving medications that
will interfere with the levels
of cabotegravir or rilpivirine.
And the cabotegravir
without rapivirine is
also used for pre-exposure
prophylaxis maintenance
therapy once every two months.
In summary, I'm not
going to read you all of
this, but it's a summary
of everything we've talked
about regarding the drug
therapy in part one.